- Hey everybody what's up?
It's Chase, welcome to
another episode of the show.
Chase Jarvis LIVE Show
here on CreativeLive
and you know this show,
this is where I sit down
with amazing humans and
I do everything I can
to unpack their brains with the goal
of helping you in your
hobby, career and, or life.
My guest today is many
things an ultra-marathoner,
an endurance athlete, a
number one New York Times
best seller and the host
of one of the top podcasts
out there in the world
called the Rich Roll Podcast.
My guest is no longer a secret,
it's Rich Roll in the house
welcome to the show buddy.
(upbeat music)
- So good to be here man.
- Thank you.
- You are like the OG in the space.
- Yes.
- I mean I don't know when
you started your stuff
- Long, long time ago.
- But it was a long time ago.
And I've been a subscriber
to your newsletter
and a watcher of your,
everything you've put out for
like I don't even remember
when it didn't exist.
- Yes, yes.
- So as somebody
who now kind of travels
in a similar space that you do
- Yeah
I just wanna thank you.
- Thank you.
- For being an inspiration
and setting an example for
like high quality content man.
- Oh stop, stop.
(Rich laughs)
- No I'm really happy to be here
and it's super cool to finally meet you.
- Thanks and we were just talking
before the camera started
rolling about we're planning
for the exchange of ideas and well
I will be on the Rich Roll
Podcast soon, we're scheming.
It's a super treat to have you on the show
and I also have noticed
your hard work from afar.
Starting one of the
first things I realized
was when you ran five Ironmans
or you did because it's more than running
there is biking and swimming.
Five in, was it five or seven
days or something like that
in Hawaii on all the different islands?
- I did this thing...
- This is freakish by the way.
- Yeah.
- This is no like, this is--
- It was a while ago.
Well it was in 2010 so the
story is my buddy Jason Lester
who's an incredible endurance athlete,
an inspirational figure.
A training partner of mine from many,
an Ultraman competition,
I would do these double
Ironman competitions.
He came up with this harebrained scheme,
this idea to try to complete five Ironmans
on five Hawaiian Islands in five days.
Literally an Ironman a day,
traveling island to island to island.
- Tell people who don't know
what an Ironman actually is.
- Yeah, for those that don't know
an Ironman a very long triathlon.
Widely considered the ultimate
test of human endurance.
Where in over the course of
one day, you swim 2.4 miles.
You ride your bike 112
miles and then you celebrate
that by running a marathon, all at once.
Super difficult and hard.
- And you wanted to stack five of those?
- Jesus, decided we should
do five of those in a row
and in between get on airplanes
and try to schlep our gear from
island to island to island.
So we took a stab at it in 2010
on May 5th, I might add.
So it was five five
on the day that we started it.
- Wow, bam bam.
- We ran into all kinds of
crazy logistical problems.
It was quite the in
certain respects a debacle
but also an amazing
challenge and adventure.
So it took us a little
bit longer than five days
but we got it done, it was crazy.
- You're making it sound
like it was two years
but it was actually like seven days or--
- It was like six and a half days.
- Yeah I mean we were
like losing bike parts,
like we had some people,
some beautiful people
who volunteered to help us.
- [Chase] Yeah.
- But we didn't have a
whole crew situation dollar
we didn't know we were doing
- Yeah, infrastructure.
No private flights.
- The crazy thing was that
the logistics were just as challenging,
it was almost a relief to just
be out on your bike doing it
because we knew we have
to finish by this time
because the last plane leaves the island.
And we have to get on that
and we have to bring all our gear,
and then we would get to the next island
and have to get to our hotel.
And by the time we ate and took a shower
it was the middle of the night
and we had two or three hours of sleep.
So the sleep deprivation
started to catch up to us
and we're, I mean it was
bananas the whole thing that.
- I remember that being widely reported
- Yeah.
- And oh my God
who is this guy?
- Right.
- I gotta meet this character man.
So and here we are
whatever years later.
- We're here.
- Well A, thanks for starting off
with the kind words around content.
You have been putting out a ton
of high-quality content as well.
The areas of focus that
I wanna talk about today
that it's my goal to assemble
world-class performers
from a whole bunch of disciplines.
And you have both achieved
an amazing physical feats,
you've also had built a
really interesting business.
But mostly your ideas
around what's possible,
see the story we just talked about,
plant-based diet something
I'm fascinated by.
The storytelling of your book.
And I think you have two books, right?
You have a cookbook that you did
with your wife is that right?
Or sort of a plant-based,
you've got your memoir.
- We've got yeah.
I wrote a memoir called Finding Ultra,
and then we have three cookbooks actually.
- Three cookbooks, cool.
Not being an only
plant-based eater I have not,
my confession here for you
is that I have not consumed the cookbooks.
But Finding Ultra is an
amazing narrative of your life
and it's not just about plant-based diet,
it's about your life.
So I'd like to start, let's
go back in time we can.
You're an endurance athlete,
what made you want to be that?
What part of you, this is a
strange part of the human brain.
- Yeah.
- That clicks into saying,
I wanna run a marathon plus 120 mile
plus a marathon, bike 120 miles
and swim two and a half, that's nuts.
And you've done crazier
stuff too by the way.
- Yeah I've done a bunch of stuff.
I mean I look at it all,
not to put too woo of a point on it
but for me it's like
all a spiritual journey
of personal growth, and
these crazy endurance races
are like a vehicle for self-discovery.
In the same way that an
artist might find that
in a photograph or in
pursuing a photograph
or a painting or making a film.
The medium for me is the outer limits
of what my body is capable of.
And I think it was originally
inspired by a couple things.
First of all I was a swimmer in college.
So I had a background as an athlete,
I swam at Stanford in the late 1980s.
We won two NCAA Championships
when I was there.
I was a benchwarmer I was by no means
a big point scorer or star on that team,
but I competed as an athlete
at a very high level.
Drugs and alcohol destroyed that career
and it really cut the head off
me achieving my potential as an athlete.
So I feel like later in life I
still had unfinished business
that I wanted to pursue to see
what I would be capable of.
And also athletics aside
when I hit around 40, 41
I was having a little bit
of an existential crisis
about what I was doing with my life.
There's a longer story baked into that
but basically I've been
pursuing this career in law.
I was on the partnership track
at a big prestigious law firm.
- Went to law at Cornell.
- I went to law at Cornell.
In the wake of problems
with drugs and alcohol
I got sober at 31 and then
spent the next nine years
trying to repair all the
wreckage that I'd created
as a result of my drinking and using,
was successful in that regard
and was very much blindly
just looking at that traditional
equation of success.
Partnership, car, house, brass ring,
the whole like traditional notion
of what it means to be a
successful male in America.
- [Chase] Yeah.
- And played that out to
the point where I realized
that there was some emptiness in that.
And had this confused state
about what I was doing with myself
because I wasn't doing it out of a passion
for the law or any of that,
I was doing it to prove to myself
and to others that I
could be a responsible,
respectful person after being
such a train wreck for so many years.
And I think trying to process
what that meant for myself
created this this sense of confusion.
And I found myself back into fitness
as a way of spending time
alone to process all of this,
to try to find a way forward.
There was never some conscious decision
that I was gonna become
this competitive athlete
in my forties and go back and
revisit unfinished business.
- [Chase] Yeah.
- It was really an organic
outgrowth out of trying to,
out of wrestling with and
trying to answer these questions
for myself about what I
was gonna do with my life.
- Now I would...
Is there a relationship
between your addiction
to drugs and alcohol and your passion,
would you call it an
addiction to exercise.
Was it, were trading one thing for,
a destructive thing for a healthy thing?
Or was there a reconciliation process
'cause I think trauma and
we all have trauma in life
and we all expressed it in different ways,
and I'm just curious how
you thought about it.
- Yeah.
I think it's a little bit of both.
What you find in the
ultra-endurance community
is a lot of people who are in recovery
from some form of abuse
or substance addiction.
And I think it would be
intellectually dishonest to say no.
I was addicted to drugs and alcohol
but my relationship with these,
doing these crazy things
is completely healthy.
Of course there's some
compulsive aspect to that.
- [Chase] Yeah.
- But I found my healthier self
through those pursuits.
Like for me taking the drink
was always the easy way out.
And getting up in the morning
to put your running shoes on
or staring down the barrel of
some crazy difficult workout,
that's a harder choice.
That requires a little bit
of backbone and character.
So for me it's been a learning experience
and it's been a positive thing.
But I do have to keep
those tendencies in check.
I'm married, I've got four kids like--
- Four? Congrats.
- Left unchecked,
like I'll move into a herd
and just train all day.
And just think about myself.
Like I'm naturally a
selfish self-seeking person.
And recovery for me is
about balancing that out
against everything else in my life,
that's truly important.
So the pendulum is always swinging
and I always have to kind
of be doing an inventory
about how I'm relating to the world
and is that in a healthy way
or is that in a very
unhealthy or compulsive way.
- I love that you said
unfinished business.
I think that it's a beautiful descriptor,
and do you feel that
you've been able to redeem
some of that business
that was that was undone?
- Certainly I mean now I look back on it,
and the idea that I needed
to redeem anything is sort of silly.
But certainly I have done that,
I mean I've been more successful
and more lauded for things
I've done athletically
than I ever was when I was
truly at my athletic peak.
- [Chase] Yeah.
- So that's been
fascinating and unexpected
and completely bizarre.
I got into these events like I said
as a sort of spiritual odyssey
to learn more about what made me tick.
The fact that anybody
else would care about that
other than maybe my wife
has been a strange journey.
And a story I'm happy to now tell
but one that was not intended
and very much unexpected.
- Well let's keep telling it.
So you, there's this desire to pursue
some spiritual awakening,
40s you can call it a midlife crisis.
Why I wanna pull on this is,
it's not not a surprise here.
There are a lot of people
who have pursued a path,
often the path whether
it was law or medicine
or doing what your father or
mother did because it was easy.
There's a lot of people who are listening
and watching right now,
who are playing this out
and saying, oh my gosh this is me.
I'm in the middle of my life
and thinking, what have I done?
I've been living the
dream than somebody else
had for me, I'm pursuing
somebody else's script
it's time I gotta write my own.
So share with us your version.
How do you reconcile those things
and get started with the next chapter.
- I wish I could give you
the three bullet points.
Here's how you do it.
- There is three points
you need to know kids.
- For me it was a long
drawn-out painful experience.
And like I said getting out of my bike
or getting out on the trail to run
or jumping in the pool or the ocean,
were almost ways of,
of connecting with myself the
in the best way that I could.
Like that time alone.
I wasn't at the time an active meditator,
and I wouldn't say that
those training sessions
were meditation proper but
they were an active meditation
that allowed me to connect
with myself in a deeper way.
In a way that I wasn't used to
that allowed me the space and the time
and the bandwidth to really
sit with my discontent
and really ponder what a
future might look like.
And what I get to do
now was not the result
of some grand scheme that I
concocted while out on the bike,
it's really been an organic outgrowth
of me making it a fundamental decision
to just start doing what felt right to me.
- [Chase] Yeah.
- To follow my instincts in my intuition
irrespective of whatever
the peanut gallery
had to say about it or whether society
was gonna launder me with
social approval or not.
To just say, look I don't care.
I like what it feels
like to jump in the pool.
I like what it feels like to
have the sun on my shoulder
on a trail run at dawn and I'm
gonna just keep doing that,
in a very childlike way, it's like play.
And as we grow up we're taught,
well this is things we don't do any more.
This is mature, respectful adult.
- Immature or not responsible.
- Exactly and I just decided
that I was gonna do it.
And I was gonna listen to that music
and I was gonna entertain it.
Not because I thought that I would find
some career path baked into
this, but just because.
And I think by continuing
to double down on that
ultimately the path has
sort of been laid forward
in front of me, brick by brick
to figure out what to do next.
But it's been very
difficult like financially
incredibly insecure we
almost lost our house.
I've had cars repossessed,
like it was not this upward trajectory
to having this podcast and getting to sit
and talk to you today.
There were a lot of
dark moments of the soul
and a lot of questioning
whether I was an insane person.
Because everyone around me
was saying what are you doing?
You could be practicing law,
you could be doing all these things,
you could be making all this money
like what you're chasing
this crazy fool's errand,
you have kids, you're being irresponsible.
So it took a lot of faith
and really conviction in order
to kind of stay true to the path.
- Was that a muscle that you'd always had?
- No, definitely not.
- Or was that a muscle
that you had to develop?
And if you had to develop
it what was your process?
- Definitely not a
muscle that I always had.
I wouldn't consider myself
an entrepreneur type personality.
I was reared very much as a safety seeker,
like just get into the best school
and like take that path,
that well trodden path.
That is laid out for men,
respectable men of your pedigree.
Like I grew up upper-middle class,
I went to really nice schools.
I have parents that took
care of all of my needs
that are still together,
I wanted for nothing
and this was kind of the trajectory
that all my peers were on.
It never occurred to
me to veer off of that
until I was really like almost soul sick.
And felt like I had no
other choice but to do that.
So for me it was very unfamiliar.
It was almost like I had to shed
a skin and grow a new one.
And my process was hardly methodical
but I would say that my wife really
was my greatest teacher
through this process.
Like she just had my back even when things
just looked crazy.
- That's so powerful.
She was like, and I was like,
I gotta go make some money
like the way that I know how to.
She'd say, "No, like
you need to keep doing
"what you're doing, we
will figure this out.
"But the path forward and the way through
"all of these difficulties
is not to retreat
"and trace your steps backwards
"but to continue to blaze forward."
And I think without that
support in the home,
I don't know that I would
have been able to keep going.
So great credit to her.
- Do you think is,
she important for you
as the person that she is
or is it important that when people
are trying to go in the same journey
that you've been through,
that there are people
that are in their corner.
Is that mentors, is it a
partner, is it a buddy?
- [Rich] Yeah.
- Of course ideally it's your spouse
because it sounds like she's she was,
is very powerful force for you.
But I'm thinking to everyone that doesn't,
what's your wife's name?
- [Rich] Julie.
- Okay to everybody who
doesn't have a Julie at home,
can you give a--
- I think it's super
critical and important
to find like-minded souls
who support your vision for yourself
and hold that space for your best self
and believe in you.
I think you need to balance that
with other people who can
give you the hard feedback
about when you're going
off-track or being a crazy person
who can give you the hard truth.
'Cause cheerleaders alone
are not gonna get you there,
you need both.
You need the tension
between the aspiration
and the grounded reality
in order to find yourself.
And I think if you, I think we all need,
I think the word mentor
I find to be problematic
because there's a formality to it.
And everyone chases the fancy name people,
I want you to be my
mentor I think everybody
has people in their community who can be
a source of truth and education for--
- And if you don't you gotta
find those people right away.
- Yeah right, you should find,
seek them out.
They are all around you,
and if you can't find
them in your neighborhood
you can find them online and you can have
a virtual relationship with somebody.
But I think it's super important
to have a board of directors.
I have people in my life
as I'm sure you do too
that I call and rely
upon for every facet of--
- [Chase] I was on the
phone this morning--
- Whether it's marriage or
parenting or profession,
all of these things.
I think it's important
to surround yourself
with people who are living the life
that you aspire to have
in certain categories.
And are further down the path in than you.
- You found both the tough love
and the cheerleader in Julie?
- Yeah.
- Sounds like.
Tell me what are some of the things
that you heard from her
that were surprising.
You just shared one which is like,
now is not the time to retreat,
now it's the time to go through.
- [Rich] Right.
- What were some other,
was there some themes
or some commonalities that you were like,
okay she's got my back?
This is what she said this
to me four or five times now
and I know, fill in the black.
- We were just getting
crushed financially.
I mean it was, looking back on
it now, it's almost comical.
Like we--
- It's only comical because
you came back on it, right?
Exactly because we're
on the other side of it,
but like I said like cars repossessed
and we had our trash bins taken away.
I mean really like embarrassing,
demoralizing stuff.
And what Julie taught me
through this whole process
was how to maintain your equanimity.
She would say your job is
to be completely neutral
like can you, because that
is like the Jedi path, right?
That is like true power to be a warrior
in the eye of a storm like that
when everything's coming
at you and you feel like
life is out of control.
If you can be neutral and
maintain your integrity,
your peace of mind your equanimity,
that's like a superpower.
So that was something
that I observed in her
that I tried to hone within myself.
I remember when the repo guy
came to take my truck away,
and she came out and
greeted him in the driveway.
And she said, "Oh hey I'm Julie.
"Would you like some tea,
do you want to come in?"
She was super nice to him
and he was so confused.
He's like what?
- He's like, wait a minute?
- Yeah I know so--
- Are they're gonna murder me
if I go there and have
tea with these people,
who are these crazies?
- The other thing,
- It's amazing.
- Is to understand
that if you're being visited
with these kinds of
difficulties in your life.
To detach from the notion
that this is failure
or a referendum on who
you are as a person,
but rather to look upon
it as an opportunity.
This is your divine moment
we are here on earth to grow,
to expand and these are lessons for us.
So our job is to pay attention
and to find the nugget
of wisdom within that
and to grab onto that and
figure out the path forward.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- So I can't overstate
the thread throughout the
hundreds of interviews
that I've personally done
with you and folks like you
and and others that have listened to
on your show and others,
that that having community,
a few or the average of the five people
you spend the most time with.
You looked around and looked at who
you're spending time with I think that is
such a common thread.
I also will jump on the same bandwagon
like the whole mentor thing
now you have people asking me to be
their mentor all the time.
And it's just like sorry
I don't even know you
but here's a community
and creating a community
and a community atmosphere
where you can learn
the fact that we're in a world where
this information is available for free.
To me I think that's
just I wanna restate that
because I think you said it
much more eloquently than I did
but it's really, really powerful
to have there not necessarily a person
but just a set of people
that you are inspired by,
that you respond to,
that you want to emulate.
And the question I have out of all this is
if you're around these people,
they're all have their own identities
and you're learning
from this person online
or this person in your life,
how did you find the part
of you in all of that?
How did you not just become
a reflection of Julie
if she was your rock in this time.
How did you find you?
- Wow that's a great question,
that's a hard question.
- [Chase] It's my job.
I mean I think I'm...
(laughs)
Yeah, that's a good one.
I think I'm still trying to find that.
I don't know that I have
arrived in that place,
I don't know if anybody
truly arrives in that place.
Like if I had to say Chase
who are you, defined yourself?
- Don't do this.
I said you're such a such a great guest
you can grab the show
and you can do--
- I'm flipping on you.
- Let me try and answer it.
- Okay.
- No actually no,
I want you to go first and I will follow,
but you should try and answer it,
don't deflect, you go.
Do you smell that, it's like--
- It's like a bakery
or something downstairs.
- Someone just kicked on the,
- I know,
smell like cinnamon buns.
- The pancakes
or the cinnamon buns, oh my goodness.
If you're at home listening and watching
I'm so bummed you can't smell
how good it smells in
this this beautiful spot
that we're in here, in hoe Ace hotel.
- There was a defining moment
for me in this whole journey
and it was after I had done
the five Ironman thing.
And I was noticing that the
media was taking an interest
in what I was doing which
as I mentioned earlier
was kind of a bizarre thing.
'Cause I was just doing this for myself.
CNN, Sanjay Gupta came to my
house did like a piece on me
and they asked, the people at CNN asked me
to write a guest blog posts for cnn.com.
Which I did and it's the
little like here's my story
and that got published and
it was tracking so well
that they put it on the CNN homepage.
And it became like the most emailed story
for you know 48 hours or 72
hours something like that.
Like it just hit a nerve and
it like track really well.
And I just got shellacked
with emails all of a sudden.
I mean this was really like,
I had never been like a
public person in any regard.
And some of these emails that came in
were just so touching and unbelievable,
like I told my story in a vulnerable way
and it gave people permission
to then tell me their story.
And I got these long you
know multi paragraph emails
like this is what happened to me
and this is what I went through
and here's my struggles and my pain.
And I was just so touched at the feeling
of trust that these people had.
And I think it was very emotional for me
to like read all these emails.
And it made me realize that
the path forward for me
and where I can really
serve is to be a cipher
for these people on the
path to transformation.
If I can be like a home
base or a safe place
for them to come to, to
confide in or to look to
for inspiration and guidance
for what the next step
for them might be, that
perhaps I had something
to say in that regard.
And so building upon that has really been
what I've done ever since that moment.
- It's interesting that there
is a true north inside of you.
You access that through
vulnerability, right?
You wrote your story out
and people responded to it,
and that gave you a feeling
and it was the feeling that you looked at
like wait a minute, this is a sign.
- [Rich] Yeah.
- That I'm doing the thing,
you talked to earlier about intuition.
Is that the same feeling,
this awareness that you had
once you'd put your,
you had to take the first step obviously.
- Right.
- Because CNN says
you wanna write this you say no,
then you might not have captured it.
But you did and then
there was that response
and the response was just like,
oh my God, A I'm not alone.
B, I like this feeling probably.
- Right.
- And maybe it sounds like
that's one of the things
that clued you off to
like I can be a home base,
maybe I can be a home base.
- Well I was very aware
that the vulnerability
was the thing that people
were connecting with.
And when I got the
opportunity to write a book
I understood that that had to be the key
sort of through line throughout
the entire narrative.
Because let's face it I'm not,
it's not like I won
some World Championship.
I've never won a race,
I've done some crazy things
in ultra-endurance but there's plenty
of athletes out there
they're a lot better than me,
that are more talented than me,
then are more accomplished than me.
So why am I being given an
opportunity to write a book?
Like it's weird, right?
It doesn't, on paper it didn't
really seem to make sense.
And so I was very aware
that the only reason
that people would connect with my story
was going to be directly
related to the extent
to which I was willing to be vulnerable
and talk about things
that aren't so comfortable
and that I'm not that proud of.
So the process of writing it really
was one of just getting into the mindset
of private journaling.
I had to make it like a diary
that no one was gonna read.
And then I would have
these moments where--
I can't believe--
- Oh my God wait,
this is gonna be a book?
I would freak out and be
paralyzed for several days.
But in retrospect looking back,
I know that that's why the
book has been successful
because it's the humanity.
Because everybody can find some aspect
of their own journey in my
pain points or my struggles.
My story isn't that remarkable,
the things that I've gone through.
Many people have gone through far worse
than what I've had to
endure to get to this place.
But I think there's there's
an integrity in that honesty,
and I think people respond to that.
They know when it's real.
- Do you think that that true north
or that beacon that thing that's inside of
in this case we're talking about you,
that was inside of you, is
that inside of everybody?
Or is that something you have to find,
is it natively there do
you have to create it?
How do people understand their true north?
- I don't know that
there's only one true north.
Maybe there's many for people
but I think the process
of trying to unlock that or
discover that within oneself
is a journey of
self-discovery that requires
rigorous self-honesty and rigorous
adherence to one's personal truth.
And I think a lot of
people are walking around
not understanding what
that is for themselves.
Like what do you mean my personal truth
like I'm just going to work
man, I'm trying to like--
- Make buck bro.
- Yeah exactly.
So in order to really connect with that
I think it's an inside job.
You can go out and ride your bike all day
or do jiu-jitsu or lose a bunch of weight,
but ultimately it's about
your relationship with you.
And that will be revealed to you
only in the moments in which you are
allowing yourself to get quiet enough.
Where you can shut off the thinking brain
or you can become an
observer of your own thoughts
and connect with your own consciousness.
And in that relationship as it develops
through meditation or mindfulness practice
or whatever strategy you employ.
I think that your higher
conscious will tell you
who it is and what it wants to be.
And your job then becomes
piecing that together,
slowly over a very long period of time.
- For you is that--
- Does that sound too obtuse?
- Not only is that not obtuse,
it's poetic, it was beautiful.
Kind of just like letting it land there.
So for you was that the trail,
was that moment of quiet,
the time the reflection,
was that the trail and
the ocean and the path?
- It was all of those things
and it was meditation,
and it was connecting with my body
for the first time in a really long time.
Again it was about learning how to connect
with my instincts and then trust them.
- Yeah.
- And these are all things
that I originally started to learn about
as a result of getting
sober and being in 12-step
and understanding that
we're spiritual beings
having a human experience.
Like these were all crazy
foreign concepts to me.
I had a decade spent in church basements
and with fellow alcoholics
and drug addicts
to acquaint me with some of these concepts
that I then started to delve deeper into.
And the physical aspect of these things
that I've done are just one
avenue of exploration for that,
but I think there's many
and it's different for everybody.
- You talked about meditation,
mindfulness, exercise, a church basement,
any others come to mind?
- It can be your faith-based community,
it can be your relationship
with your kids.
It can be sitting in a cave,
it can be of a personal retreat.
It can be like I just
said, learning jiu-jitsu,
it can be going out in nature
and taking photographs,
it could be what you do.
I think it's about finding
what lights your own spark
and then trusting your instincts enough
to pull on that thread
and continue to follow it
with the understanding that more
will be revealed to you in time.
- So was it a Rumi quote I don't remember
we're gonna botch this
but it's a fair to say
I'm gonna try and summarize
but someone else's quote.
That you don't have to
see the whole staircase
you just have to find the first stair.
- I think that's super profound.
I think so many people especially
in this kind of self-help
rubric or universe
that we're kind of part of,
everybody wants to know all
the steps before they begin.
- Because then they're gonna decide,
they're gonna say hmm.
- [Rich] Yeah.
- First to get hard and
I have to sweat and cry.
- Right.
- And bleed for this,
I'm not sure I want it so can you show me
what it looks like around the corner.
And most people that I
know that are already good
they're like sorry there that's just,
you've got to take the first...
- You gotta take the first step.
I mean use running as
an example like well,
what watch do I need?
What shoes do I need?
I need my training plan, is
that the right training plan
or should I do this training plan?
Which race should I sign up for?
Its analysis paralysis that
keeps people stuck forever
because they wanna
understand the entire journey
from beginning to end.
- [Chase] Yeah.
- And what they're failing
to realize or understand
or embrace is that the beauty
of the whole experience
is in the unknowing, that's
where the faith comes in.
You take that first step and it's just fog
in front of you, you don't
know and you have to trust.
And you have to be willing
to take that leap of faith
into the unknown and believe
that you will be caught,
that you will be cradled
somehow and that's scary.
- Yeah
- It's frightening.
It was frightening for me
but that's the magic man.
And I don't wanna deprive
somebody of that experience
because that's where all the beauty
and the self understanding and the faith
and the sense of self comes from.
- You have four kids.
How are you, how or what are you doing
to imprint some of this
just gold into their lives?
Is there parenthood,
(Rich coughs)
now this is parenting advice
or it's just a comment or sort of trying
to understand humanity, but are you?
- Well.
- The chance of them
listening to this are low.
- Trust me they're not gonna listen.
(Rich laughs)
- Yeah, exactly.
- They couldn't be less interested
in anything that I'm doing, but--
- What are their ages?
- So--
- Unless if you're...
- So I've got two boys,
they are my stepsons
that I've lived with since
they were three and four
but they're now 22 and 23.
And they've moved out of the house,
they're musicians and a band
with my nephew, their cousin.
And they're working on their first album,
so they're pursuing their dream
and they're incredibly talented.
I have no doubt that they'll be successful
they're kind of embedded
into the music scene
of East Los Angeles and it's super cool
to see them fully engaged
in what they wanna be
doing with their lives.
Then I've got two daughters
that are 15 and 11.
15 year old daughter it's a tricky,
that's a tricky universe.
And she's a visual artist and she goes
to an Arts High School
in downtown Los Angeles.
That's required our family
to kind of reconfigure
how we live because it's very
far from our other house.
So my wife and I are now splitting time,
staying in an apartment that we rented
that's approximate to the school
so that we can be in full
support of her dream.
- Wow.
- So putting our money
where our mouth is as we were saying
before the podcast started.
- I was like well that a
big move, man it's like...
- I was telling Chase how how I've spent
half the week in downtown LA
which is where we're
recording this right now
to be in support of our daughter.
And I can't be somebody who
is a public-facing individual
telling people to pursue
what's in their heart
if I'm not actively engaged in supporting
my own daughter and doing that.
So that's made our lives a little bit
complicated right now, but it's been cool.
And then our other daughters 11
and she goes to school
back near our other house.
So life is not simple
but it's also beautiful
and I can't say that I have
all the parenting answers.
I think if there's one
piece of parenting advice
that I would give that has been helpful
and has worked for us,
it's that we have chosen to
treat our kids like conscious
sentient individuals
from a very young age.
Rather than talk down
to them like little kids
to give them a sense of
sovereignty and respect
at an early age in an effort to
urge them or prompt them
to develop their own
personal sense of self
and self-esteem at an early age.
And I think that that has
worked out quite well so far.
- Agency.
- Agency correct that's
the word I was looking for.
- Yeah it's weird that that's not a,
that that's not a product
that is widely taught.
- [Rich] Right.
- The school system if you look
at the traditional and I was--
- It's quite the opposite.
- Yeah, I was raised in middle
lower, middle class family.
I didn't also want for
much but I also had Nikes
that are upside-down Nike shoes
and I didn't really
understand the difference
until I did one day I was like,
wait a minute how come
my Nikes are upside down.
How come my Adidas have more stripes.
But as far as the basics I had them.
But the concept of,
and not my parents, my
parents are amazing loving,
they're still together I was an only child
so I basically had the
attention of my parents.
But it wasn't like I was,
hey man this is a thing you
have agency you can do whatever.
They're very practical,
they're very supportive
even when I told them what I wanted to do
but it's weird to me that we
don't have culturally embedded
the idea of agency and choice
and autonomy and sovereignty,
some of the words that
you used right there.
What are we doing wrong?
- We're doing so many things wrong.
I mean our whole education
system needs to be upended.
It was founded on these,
in era of industrialization,
ideas about how to create a
healthy worker for the system.
- [Chase] Yeah.
- And now we're all
carrying supercomputers
around in our pockets that
can tell us the answer
to any question that we have
and yet we have an educational system
that's founded upon memorization
and like rote skills
that I think the relevancy have now
been called into question.
And what we need to do
is teach children agency,
teach them how to think for themselves,
teach them how to be creative
in their problem-solving skills.
How to be team members and team leaders.
Like all of these things
that I think are essential
to being successful in our modern life,
are just not even part of the conversation
when it comes to education.
And I find that disheartening,
it puts more pressure on the parents
to instill those things in the kids
and kids that have solid
parents are gonna get that.
But I think it should
be the responsibility
of our educational system to be teaching
the life skills that I never
learned when I was growing up.
- That's part of the reason
that CreativeLIVE exists
because I didn't see that in the world.
- Right, can you imagine
being like 12 or 13 years old
and being able to open up a laptop
and like learn about the world
with all this free content
of amazing wise people teaching you.
Whatever it is that you wanna learn,
like that was not available to me.
And what is the impact of
that on culture and society
and a young person's mind.
Is college relevant anymore?
For certain people it is but I think
for a lot of people, it isn't.
There are so many new and
innovative ways to learn
and I think we're becoming
more and more a skill-based
and a freelance based economy.
And that's very different from
the traditional programming
of the typical university
or collegiate structure.
And yet those institutions have yet
to kind of mature,
to what's actually happening right now.
- For sure they're they're
actually disincentivized
- [Rich] Yeah.
- They have billions of
dollars with a real estate
they need you to physically
come and stand there.
Sure there's benefits
for in-person community.
- [Rich] Of course.
- IRL you know all about
it but not everything
and not all the time.
You're speaking my language for sure
when you're saying these things
that systems based on the factory
which was a Prussian system
that was invented in the 1800s
for moving people
effectively through a line
and training whether they're soldiers
or the Industrial Revolution.
You wanna a factory,
it aims produce widgets
that all look the same, act the same
and go do a rote job 99% of those
which don't exist anymore.
- [Rich] Right.
- All that is so true.
You said something
interesting it's like the job
of you know, a job of parents
is to teach their kids these things.
And I think there's a lot of people
just like clicked for me
while you were talking that
it's not just the parents
and the kids because the
people who are listening
to this most of them are the adults.
And there's the same
mentality is present in
well you is 41, right and
so if you're listening
and any of this is resonating with you,
it's not just about your
13 year old daughter.
This is could be about you as well.
And I know we happily
skirted my personal story
but I'm gonna bring it back here
as I did all of the same
stuff you're talking about.
The same track that's culturally approved.
Go to college I also was an
athlete, soccer scholarship.
All the right things check the boxes,
got up high fives from the right people.
And yet at early 20s
felt so lost,
so confused and it was actually
the deep shame that I felt
by letting down all of the people
in my life that I had basically
been telling a lie to for years.
And I did not have a rough
or a sad, I mean it was fine.
But I was definitely not doing my thing,
I was doing somebody else's thing.
And it was the shame and the guilt
and the ultimate
overcoming of those things
that as soon as I had
said, hey you know what
this whole like a doctor thing
I could give two shits
about being a doctor.
In fact it sounds terrible.
- Right.
- Remember all those volunteer
hours that I had to do to
get into medical school,
they do those for a reason
because you need to really love it
and I hated it every second,
every second I was at the
hospital I hated it and--
- And the moment that you
decide to trust yourself
and follow your gut and your instincts
you're overwhelmed with guilt
that you're letting other people down.
- For sure and--
- That you're not entitled
to be able to do that for yourself.
- And I did a lot of extra
school outside of it,
I went to graduate school
and did a lot of things
that were dancing around the thing
that I knew is my truth and
I was basically juggling
and hopping on one leg and being a monkey
for the other people in my
life, who are lovely people,
beautiful, supportive, I
mean it's not like they're,
no one was holding a gun to
my head no one was saying.
But it was just like
culture and I'll also say
I'm born white, I'm born male.
- [Rich] Yeah.
- Born in America.
- Lets just straight
acknowledge the privilege.
- Radical privilege and
so if I'm sitting here
like boo-hooing poor me how hard this was
to just finally realize that I
was living someone else's lie
and tell the people
that remember that money
you spent for me in
graduate school or whatever
like that's all wasted.
- [Rich] Yeah.
- Because I never wanted
to do it from day one.
I had to do it to figure it out probably.
But like that for every
one of those aspects of me
there's more guilt and shame around.
And you know what imagine if
I didn't have both my parents,
or if I was actually poor.
And came from a,
I wasn't white and male.
And all these advantages,
so I had all kinds of guilt
and stuff piled on to that.
And I will what I'll confess here is that
it was in playing through that.
Just actually okay I just told my parents
I'm not gonna do that.
And I'm looking at my student loan debt
and it's $67,000 dollars.
And you sit in that for a little bit,
like you know what I can
actually be okay with this.
It wasn't like that honest,
I don't wanna go plate this thing
because it was a lot of pain.
But I wanna know a little bit about yours.
That was mine, how are you,
did you have to sit,
you mentioned 10 years
in church basements, was that the sitting
with the fact that you
disappointed all those things
that helped you find your true north.
You talked about it being on the trail,
you talked about not knowing everything
but knowing one thing,
can you tell me what it was like to?
- Yeah it's been kind of
up and down like this.
I mean I grew up
in a very education focused household.
Was definitely a top priority
and I struggled
academically for a long time
and then finally figured it out
when I was in high school and--
- What was it that you figured out.
I figured out that although I wasn't
academically gifted,
I realized that I had a capacity
to be a workhorse.
And that's something that
I've used as well in the pool
and in sports that I'm not the smartest,
I'm not the most gifted athletically
but I know how to fucking work,
and I know how to suffer
and I'll get it done.
I cannot work that guy next to me,
and that that served me in the classroom
served me in swimming pool
and all these other areas of life.
And and I was able to
kind of stake my claim
on that character trait.
So by the time I was
graduating high school,
top student in my class I got
into like every college I
applied to all the fancy schools.
And was also a top swimming
recruit, so I had my pick.
And I went to Stanford which
was like number one school,
number one swimming program,
the world was my oyster.
It was just this clear skies ahead,
upwardly mobile trajectory for me.
And then enter drugs and alcohol
and that just completely screwed me up.
Sent me down a dark path
for many, many years
until I met my maker with that
and was forced to get sober.
But along the way had really destroyed
a lot of relationships and
trust with a lot of people.
Had decimated my career,
basically there was a lot
of wreckage in my path.
So I went from this guy who is like
this guy's gonna be a senator.
- Clear skies.
To you know to two dirtbag status
and then had to inch my way
back to regain that trust.
So even, so when I got sober
and I'm being introduced
to these spiritual concepts
and I'm being forced to confront
the truth of my actions.
And I'm trying to connect with myself
for the very first time.
I mean when you medicate
throughout your entire adolescence
and twenties you're creating a barrier
between you and your
consciousness the entire time.
- [Chase] Yeah.
- When you finally remove that
you're this bundle of nerves
you don't know who you are,
it's very confusing and disorienting
and it took many years of
me trying to figure out
who am I, what makes me tick?
And during that process
I still was very attached
to this idea of the American dream.
Not because I had some passion for it
but it was really an external pressure
of like I need to prove that I can,
that I'm not this dirtbag,
that I can be this respectful person.
That that person that I was in high school
that I can show my
parents and everybody else
that that's truly who I am,
but that was all bullshit.
- [Chase] Yeah that was
still law school path.
- Right and it took me
a decade to understand
that for myself and to let go
of that which is terrifying.
Let go of this idea that you
promised your entire life on
for as far back as you can remember
is a sense of free fall,
I'm sure it's what you experienced.
And when you're a safety seeker like I wa
you always know what the
next thing is gonna be.
You're kind of going from here
and then this is what you do
and then this is what
happens to let go of that
and have no true north or not no sense
of what that next step is gonna be is,
was scarier than going to rehab.
It was scarier than any
of the endurance races
that I've done, it's a
sense of disorientation
that is really hard to describe.
- Thanks for being so vulnerable
and for sharing that, that's--
- I don't know if I
answered your question.
- You nailed it oh man like in spades.
That I love the journey
of moving from there
into your the physical fitness
and in Finding Ultra, your memoir,
let's talk about the plant-based diet.
I think that's a huge
part of what I understand
externally as something you identify with.
Can you give me, is it
a personal philosophy?
Is it a health-based philosophy
that all those things, some none.
Give me the little plan. Man.
(Rich coughs)
'Cause I'm like Rich Roll
plant-based everything
and you've got great merchandise and--
- Right well I would say,
rather than slap a label on it
and say this is how I identify,
it's probably better to just tell a story.
- [Chase] Great.
- And that story is very wedded
to the story that I've been telling you,
which is throughout my 30s,
sober trying to repair
my life and establish
myself as this respectful person.
I had taken a lot of those
addictive alcoholic tendencies
and placed them not on
fitness but on work.
I was very much a workaholic and um,
so much so that by the time
I was 39 I was 50 pounds overweight.
I was never like a big morbidly obese guy,
but I was like a hefty heavy guy
who was essentially a
couch potato like I hadn't,
despite the fact that I had
been this athlete in college
I was not taking care
of myself physically.
I was just working and
subsisting on fast food
and shitty lifestyle habits and the like.
So by the time I was 39 I was kind
of like a wreck physically.
and that's when I was having
this existential crisis.
So I'm confused about what
I'm doing with my life
and this kind of perfect storm percolated
that in which this existential crisis
that I was having collided
with a health scare,
where I was walking up a
simple flight of stairs
to go to bed after a long day at work
one evening and had to pause.
I don't want to be
overly dramatic about it
but I'd tightness in my chest.
And as somebody who thought
of himself as an athlete
to have to like take a break walking up
a flight of stairs because
you're out of breath
was like this is, I'm 30.
- What's happening here?
- I'm not that old I'm 39.
Sweat on my brow and kind of buckled over
and it was a symbolic
moment in which I realized
that the way I was living
my life was just untenable.
I needed, it was another bottom for me.
It was similar to the day
that I decided to get sober.
I had this palpable strong sense
that once again I was
having one of those moments
that if I had the awareness
and the presence of mind
to really feel in that moment
could be a catalyst for
another major lifestyle change.
I was very aware of that in that moment
and I didn't know what that meant.
All I knew is that I needed to jump on it
and take advantage of it
right away or it would pass.
Like that day that I went to rehab
if I decided well maybe tomorrow who knows
what would have happened.
I knew that there was an urgency to it
and that urgency required
some specific actions
that needed to be undertaken.
And for me that translated into,
I went immediately into this seven day
juice fast cleanse thing.
Not because, I felt like I needed to
I had toxins that, whatever.
I just needed to do something hard.
- Yeah massive action.
Tell me about it.
- I'd never gone a day
without eating food.
I was like this is like going to rehab
for food and lifestyle.
And it was hard it was very difficult
but at the end of that seven-day period
of basically just subsisting on juice,
fruit juice and vegetable juice.
I had this resurgence in vitality
that was kind of amazing.
Like I couldn't believe that
after a week of not eating
I suddenly felt better than I'd felt
and as long as I could remember.
And that triggered me into this journey
to try to find a way of eating
that would allow me to
feel that way all the time.
And that was a messy
experience of many months
of trying lots of different things
but ultimately settling into
eating a plant only diet.
That was the one thing that I tried
that actually allowed me to feel vital
throughout the day in
a very balanced manner
in a way that I surprised
me, I wasn't expecting that.
So my adoption,
- You didn't seek.
I wasn't like no I'm
gonna be this vegan now.
Like I was just trying to
find a way to feel good.
- [Chase] Yeah.
- It was very much a selfish
health oriented goal.
Eating plants worked
and so I've just been
doing that ever since.
- Yeah when you find
something that works for you-
- Yeah and so it's important to me
that people understand that I'm not coming
from this super dogmatic place.
I've been doing it now for 12 years
and it still works great for me.
And I promised myself that if at any point
I came to a crossroads
where I wasn't feeling good
or it felt like something
was awry or amiss
that I would be intellectually honest
about that and address it.
And if that meant that I needed to go
and eat other types of foods
that I had to entertain that possibility.
I mean that day hasn't come yet.
- [Chase] Yeah.
- I still feel great, 52 I'm still able
to go out and kill it.
And what this journey has taught me has,
this journey has taught me so much
like now my interest in this lifestyle
and way of eating has
expanded beyond the parameters
of just my waistline and my
personal sense of vitality
to our collective responsibility
to care for the well-being of our planet
and all of these sentient animals.
I think we can all agree
we don't treat so great
particularly in a factory farming context.
And to help people kind
of better understand that
and create a connection between the foods
that we're eating and
where they come from.
Because the whole system is erected
to prevent us from
really being emotionally
and intellectually
connected to that process.
- I think that arc is
really cool and natural.
And it's not like everyone comes into,
probably for their own reasons
and on their own path.
Yours that moment walking up the stairs,
so it's such a focused moment.
What about those of us I'll
put myself in this category
knock on wood no health scares, feel good.
How do you tap into a thing
that you don't even know you're missing?
- Yeah I mean that's the
secret sauce right there.
And again I wish I had
a pithy answer for that
'cause for me pain is really been,
when I'm in enough pain like
then I can move the needle
and I can make the changes, right?
And the big changes that
I've made in my life
have been a result of being in
a tremendous amount of pain.
But let's square that
with the understanding
and the realization that those changes
and those choices are
always available to us.
We need not suffer in
order to avail ourselves
of what they have to offer.
So how can we make the choice
without the suffering, right?
- [Chase] Yeah.
(Rich laughs)
Yes, it's very proactive of you.
I don't know.
- That's hard, yeah like who does that?
You know what I mean?
- [Chase] Tim Ferriss.
- Right yeah certain alien
humans that are able to do that.
But I think it's about,
it goes back to that mind,
body, soul connection.
It's about being present with who you are
and I think meditation is really
the superpower skill that can create
a sense of awareness
to be in a situation to make that choice.
- [Chase] Yeah.
- Because I think we're all visited
with like whether it's the
moment I decided to go to rehab
or that line in the sand
moment of like I'm changing my,
who would have thought
that a staircase episode
and a decision to like change my diet
would deliver me to sitting
next to you to do this?
It's like it's insane
right you can't imagine
or predict these things,
but I think that we're all
visited with these moments.
And if you're paying attention
if you're present with yourself
you're more likely to
be aware when they are,
when they descend upon you as opposed to
blindly reacting to your environment
and just bumping up
against what is happening.
And then missing the gift
and allowing it to pass.
- Yeah that self awareness, mindfulness,
meditation that whole space
has been transformational
for me personally.
I think it's as you said earlier
I think you described it as a vehicle
or a path or a grounding element
to be able to be attuned
to all that stuff.
- Well I think a better, yeah agreed.
And I think maybe a more
concrete way of putting it is
if you're on the wrong path for yourself,
the universe is gonna let you know.
It's gonna knock softly at first
and if you're not listening
and it's gonna start to knock
louder and louder and louder.
And if you continue to not pay attention
to not have the wherewithal
or the mindfulness
to course-correct then you're
gonna end up in a car crash
a metaphorical one.
There's gonna be some situation
that arises or cataclysm
that is gonna force you
to finally confront this thing
that you're refusing to look at.
So the question becomes
like can you course-correct
when the knock is gentle?
And again it goes back to being aware.
The more aware you are the more present,
the more mindful you are of
your surroundings and yourself
the more likely you're going
to be able to take notice.
- Can I ask a couple more questions
about the plant-based diet?
- [Rich] Sure.
- What about blood type stuff.
Is that shaky science or I'll just--
- I'm not a doctor, I'm not a nutritionist
and I'm not a scientist
and I don't play one on the internet.
But I will tell you that I'm Type O which,
- Yeah.
- From what I understand
is the is the type that
is supposed to eat meat.
- Meat.
Yeah, I had never heard this.
I find myself craving protein
and I have protein, animal-based
protein I feel better.
And again this would be a psychology,
I have not, I've done some
plant-based only for some time
or I haven't done like the master cleanse
or anything, I've had
some small versions of it.
I'm intrigued by the
footprint on the planet.
I'm intrigued by just balance
and doing what's right,
but also I can't get
out of the cycle of like
- Yeah.
- Craving hardcore dose
of protein so.
- Cravings are unreliable
narrators though at times.
I mean there is undoubtedly a connection
between the quality of your microbiome
and the signals that are
being sent to your brain
that get translated into cravings.
So sometimes that craving is real,
it's because your body
really does need something.
Sometimes it's because your microbiome
is saying this is what we like
or it is just habit that gets triggered
where you're uncomfortable
not setting it in that way.
And I think to really
understand the difference
you have to weather those
cravings for a period of time,
whether it's 30 days
or something like that,
to see how legitimate they really are.
And only you know and
everybody's different.
I'm the first person to say like,
look I can only speak
from my own experience.
I'm sharing from a place of
personal experience only.
- Yeah, it worked for me.
Yeah, it's great.
- Right, so.
- Tell me a little bit about the cookbooks
I want people to be able to
find them on the internet.
- Yeah so in the wake
of writing Finding Ultra
and telling my story it seemed natural
that the next book ought to be about food.
Because food plays such a big role
in my own personal evolution
and what I've been able to do athletically
and people were interested
and how that works.
So we wrote a cookbook
called The Plant Power Way
which is very family-friendly
introductory primer
to eating a plant-based diet,
with recipes that are super traditional.
Like potato salad and lasagna.
There's this sense that if
you're eating a plant-based diet
you're gonna be crawling
around in your yard
chewing grass out of it.
(Chase laughs)
Or just eating salad and celery
and that's certainly
not the way that I eat.
- [Chase] How do you eat?
- I push my body like I'm
very physically active
and I have a huge appetite,
I need a lot of food.
And I wanna feel like those,
what I'm putting in my in my mouth
is gonna stick to my ribs.
So this book is sort of
intended to serve that,
and my wife is incredible
cook they're all her recipes.
And then we wrote another cookbook
called The Plantpower Way: Italia.
We do these retreats in the
Italian countryside every year.
We take groups of 30 to 40 people
through a seven-day experience
that involves meditation
and trail running and mindfulness
and a lot of intense workshops.
But of course also food and collaborating
with the chefs of that region
produced this amazing cookbook
that is a plant-based spin
on your favorite Italian recipes.
- Best place for people to find
and track you down on the internet?
- Easy to find just
you can google my name,
there is richroll.com is my website
where everything it goes on.
- Home base.
- The podcast it's just
The Rich Roll Podcast,
wherever you listen to find podcasts.
And they're available on YouTube as well.
- Amazing.
- So yeah.
As is this, thank you so much
for being a guest on my podcast,
think speaking of podcast.
- Appreciate it man.
- And I'm looking forward
to being on yours,
we've already agreed it's happening.
- [Rich] Yeah, yeah, yeah cool.
- Thank you so much
for sharing your story.
The insights, the vision.
It's an incredibly inspiring.
- Thanks man.
And I got work to do.
(laughs)
I know about that.
But I can tell you it is an honor
to meet you and be on your show
as a longtime fan of
everything that you do
and put out into the world
with the highest degree of integrity.
It's been a pleasure man.
- Thank you so much
and for everybody out there listening
check out Rich's stuff
everywhere on the internet
and thank you for tuning in.
Hopefully see you, hear from you,
you'll see me or whatever
on the internet, tomorrow.
(gentle music)